here with more senator ted cruz the
great state of texas senator
i don't know i don't recall you denying
riots for riots last year i don't know
any republican
that wasn't out there saying we need to
restore law and order
and i don't know any republican that was
out there or conservative saying we need
to defund and dismantle the police but
if you remember
please tell us because my memory is
pretty sharp on these issues
well sean i gotta say it's remarkable
that the white house is now apparently
employing comedians
you know there's an old yiddish word for
that
uh yet you know for them to run out and
claim that it's republicans who want to
defund the police
that's like an arsonist showing up at
the fire and blaming the firemen that's
like the chinese
blaming the americans for the wuhan
virus
that's like oj saying he's going to help
find
the real killer that's like democrats
saying
they're the ones that want to build the
wall it's absurd
it's ridiculous and they know it but you
know what they're also counting on the
media
all encircling joe biden and saying poor
uncle joe
he doesn't want to abolish your police
well last time i checked bill de blasio
the democratic mayor of new york
campaigned on defunding the police cut a
billion dollars from the nypd and you
know what de blasio was standing on that
same
democratic stage with joe biden you
might not remember it but de blasio was
right there last i checked
aoc is a democrat last i checked talibs
a democrat
last i checked omar is a democrat last i
checked
the summer of love you remember when you
had the chas autonomous zone and you had
a democrat going
oh it's just the summer of love i mean i
want to see the democrats make the case
to the american people put us in charge
like the mayor of portland can say
put us in charge let us abolish your
police if you don't like your your
murder rate we can increase it
eight times 800 percent
look the democrats understand they're in
trouble abolishing the police is
stupid the american people know that by
the way african-americans and hispanics
overwhelmingly oppose
abolishing the police and so so suddenly
these rich white liberals
that said let them eat cake let them be
without police
are realizing oh no this is unpopular
and so they're trying to claim these
aren't the droids you're looking for
they've never supported it it's absurd
it's ridiculous and sean if you want to
know what joe biden thinks
look no further than two of the senior
officials he appointed to the department
of justice fanita gupta
and kristin clark they are two of the
leading
advocates for defunding and abolishing
the police last year in writing and
congressional testimony
they advocated it biden appointed them
to two of the top
positions in the department of justice
and by the way out of 50 democrats in
the senate you know how many voted to
confirm both of them
all 50 every single democrat
voted to confirm vocal advocates for
abolishing the police
that's who's helping run the department
of justice right now let me ask you
as a constitutional attorney that has
successfully great track record actually
argued before the united states supreme
court and and even
alan dershowitz said you were one of the
brightest students
that he ever had the honor of of having
in his class
um you know i understand that our
constitution
and you step in and correct me at any
point i'm wrong i understand it to be
the
the foundation for our rule of law in
this
great democratic republic we live in uh
when we have laws i always thought you
don't get to pick and choose which ones
you decide to obey
your state of texas all our border
states now
are living with record lawlessness
the highest number of people coming into
the country illegally
not only are they just being processed
and allowed to enter
but then it seems like joe biden kamala
harris's policies are aiding and
abetting in the law breaking
as they then disperse and and and give
travel assistance to illegal immigrants
to
other states all over the country is
there anything legal about that senator
because
i'll be down at the border with greg
abbott who i'm very fond of and
with president trump tomorrow
yeah look as you know it's complete
lawlessness and the biden administration
refuses to enforce the law a couple of
months ago
i brought 19 senators down to the border
to see firsthand what was happening i've
been to the border
many many times i've been out with a
border patrol on midnight patrol
it is worse than it's ever been over a
half million people
have crossed illegally and i got to tell
you for many of the people who are
crossing illegally
they don't even have to be apprehended
by the border patrol they go and seek
out the border patrol and turn
themselves in because joe biden and
kamala harris
deliver them the rest of the way joe
biden and kamala harris
are the last mile of the human
trafficking network that's resulting in
abusing
thousands of little boys thousands of
little girls it's utterly lawless and
it's striking
so one of the things the trip that
president trump is taking to the border
and we're glad to welcome him back in
texas
it did prompt kamala harris finally to
discover we had a southern border
and she traveled to the southern border
but amazingly enough she didn't go to
the rio grande valley she didn't go
to the epicenter of the problem she went
to el paso which is a wonderful city
but it's 800 miles away it is it is
chicago is closer to washington dc than
el paso is to the rio grande valley
and there's a reason sean that kamala
didn't go to the rio grande valley
because if she
if she had she would have had to have
seen the biden
cages you've seen the biden cages
cage after cage of little children
and she didn't want the news media to
cover it because you know the media
today
they don't pretend anymore they are are
the praetorian guard
protecting biden and harris and and and
so she went to el paso to say see i went
to the border everything's fine here
while ignoring we're on a pace for more
than 2
million people to cross illegally it is
a crisis
and you want to know how bad it is
mcallen texas great city down in the rio
grande valley
historically bright blue 80 percent
democratic they just elected a
republican mayor because the people said
enough already with this chaos that joe
biden kamala harris has given us
we need to enforce our law we need to
secure the borders senator
uh that would be a good start i thought
laws i don't think i never knew you
could pick and choose the laws i never
thought a president and vice president
could pick and choose either
uh i get to be in your home state of
texas i happen to have reported from the
border i think this will be my 15th time
being down there from the rio grande all
the way through san diego
at the actual border by the way just in
case anyone's interested
senator uh look forward to seeing your
stuff buy property in texas we want to
make you a texan sean
listen i'm getting out of here i promise
you